.
>> Neil: YOU ALWAYS THINK OF
THE ONE THEY ALWAYS CATCH THINK
YOU VERY MUCH, WILL THE
PRESIDENT SAID THAT THE PROBLEM
IS WITH THESE GOVERNORS, LIKE
GOVERNOR ABBOTT, AND
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS OF FLORIDA,
WHO ARE SHIPPING OFF MIGRANTS TO
PLACES FAR BETWEEN HE END.
LOOK AT THIS.
>> REPUBLICS ARE PLAYING
POLITICS WITH HUMAN BEINGS,
USING THEM AS PROPS.
>> President Biden: WHAT THEY
ARE DOING IS RECKLESS, AND WE
HAVE A PROCESS IN PLACE TO
MANAGE MIGRANTS AT THE BORDER,
WE ARE WORKING TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT IS SAFE, ORDERLY, AND HUMANE.
>> Jackie: THE PRESIDENT WAS
SPECIFICALLY REFERRING TO THIS
LANE THAT THEY GOT OFF IN THE
MARTHA'S VINEYARD AND
MASSACHUSETTS.
>> Neil: AND MARTHA'S
VINEYARD, THAT WAS A POLITICAL
STUNT, THAT WAS EGREGIOUS,
SAYING THE SAME ABOUT
GOVERNOR ABBOTT'S MOVE SING THE
SAME ABOUT MIGRANTS WHO FOUND
THEIR WAY TO WASHINGTON, D.C.,
CHICAGO, NEW YORK, SANCTUARY
CITIES, ALL.
AND IT GOT US THINKING HERE, OF
THIS OUTRAGE THAT HAS BEEN
EXPRESSED.
I ALWAYS WONDER WHAT WE THINK OF
OURS AT THE PUBLIC DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC SAFETY BECAUSE, CHRIS, I
CAN WELL REMEMBER, WASN'T THAT
LONG AGO WHEN ANDY CONTINUES TO
THIS DAY, WHERE THE
ADMINISTRATION, AND ICE, MORE
SPECIFICALLY HAS HAD MORE THAN
900 FLIGHTS CARRYING MORE THAN
51,009 THAT U.S. CITIZENS ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY, SOUNDED WITHIN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT AND VERY
FEW AND THOSE AFFECTED AREAS
SAID BOO ABOUT ANYTHING.
EVEN THOUGH IN MOST CASES, THEY
WERE NOT WARNED AT ALL.
BUT, NOW, THESE COUPLE OF
INSTANCES BECOME THE FOCUS.
WITH NO REFERENCE TO THOSE TENS
OF THOUSANDS TRANSFERRED UNDER
THIS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT
PROGRAM.
WHAT YOU THINK.
>> Chris: RIGHT NOW, YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
WE KNOW OVER 1 MILLION ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS HAVE BEEN RELEASED
INTO THE EVER SINCE LAST YEAR.
AND RIGHT NOW, WE DO NOT KNOW
WHERE THOSE IMMIGRANTS ARE AT.
END OF COURSE, THERE WAS NO
ACKNOWLEDGMENT, THERE WAS NO
CONCERNS AT THAT POINT, FROM
ANYBODY FROM THESE MAYORS, OR
FROM ANY LOCAL OFFICIALS AND
SOME OF THE CITIES, SOME OF
THESE DATES FOR WHERE THESE
IMMIGRANTS ARE BEING BUSED AND
THROWN TO BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
BUT NOW, THAT TEXAS, FLORIDA,
AND ARIZONA ARE NOW TAKING THIS
INITIATIVE TO BUS IMMIGRANTS
FROM THEIR STATES TO THESE AT
SANCTUARY CITIES, IT IS CAUSING
CONCERN.
AGAIN, AND I MENTIONED THIS
NUMEROUS TIMES ON YOUR SHOW.
THEY ARE ONLY EXPERIENCING A
SMALL FRACTION OF WHAT TEXAS
EXPERIENCES EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND GOVERNOR ABBOTT LODGE IS HIS
INITIATIVE HAS BUS OR INITIATIVE
TO BUS THESE IMMIGRANTS TO
WASHINGTON, TO NEW YORK, AND NOW
CHICAGO BECAUSE THE SMALLER
BORDER COMMUNITIES WERE FEELING
OVERRUN BY EMIGRANTS.
THEY DO NOT HAVE THE CAPACITY,
BORDER PATROL DOES NOT HAVE THE
PROCESS TO HOUSE THE AMOUNT OF
IMMIGRANTS THAT ARE COMING
ACROSS DAILY.
SO, TO ALLEVIATE THAT WE ARE
BUSING IMMIGRANTS FROM TEXAS TO
THE CITIES.
AND ONE THING I WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE VERY CLEAR IS THAT THESE
IMMIGRANTS ARE NOT BEING
TRAPPED.
THEY ARE DEFINITELY NOT BEING
KIDNAPPED.
THERE WERE ALLEGATIONS THAT WERE
BEING MADE BY THE GOVERNOR OUT
OF CALIFORNIA.
THESE IMMIGRANTS HAVE GONE
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND SYSTEM,
THEY HAVE GONE THROUGH THE
NGOs, THEY HAVE BEEN RELEASED.
AND NOW ALL WE ARE DOING IS
FACILITATING THE TRANSPORT TO
THE SANCTUARY CITIES BECAUSE
THESE IMMIGRANTS, THAT IS WHERE
THEY WANT TO GO BECAUSE THEY
KNOW FOR A FACT THAT THEY WILL
RECEIVE BENEFITS AND THEY WILL
BE WELCOMED BY THESE AT
SANCTUARY CITIES AS THESE MAYORS
AND THE AS OTHER LOCAL OFFICIALS
HAVE TOUTED SINCE THE VERY
BEGINNING THAT THEY ARE A CITY
OF IMMIGRANTS.
SO THAT IS ALL WE ARE DOING
RIGHT NOW, AND IT IS CAUSING
CONCERN BECAUSE NOW, IT IS
FORCING THE MAYOR, IT IS FORCING
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
ACTUALLY ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT IS
TAKING PLACE.
BECAUSE GOVERNOR ABBOTT AND ALL
THESE OTHER GOVERNORS THAT ARE
TAKING PART IN THIS BUSING AND
SUPPLYING THESE IMMIGRANTS IS
TAKING A LINE OF WHAT'S TAKING
PLACE OF THE BORDER AND IT'S
FORCING THEM TO ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT
IS TAKING PLACE.
BUT WE STILL HAVE NOT SEEN ANY
STRATEGY, OR ANY PLAN FOR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO DO
ANYTHING ABOUT THE INFLUX OF
IMMIGRANTS.
WE SEE EL PASO IS NOW
EXPERIENCING AN INFLUX OF
IMMIGRANTS WHICH THEY HAVE NEVER
DOUBTED BEFORE.
SO IT IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO
ESCALATE.
>> Neil: EYEBALL FOR
CRITICIZING BUT IF YOU'RE GOING
TO CRITICIZE SOMETHING YOU
BETTER BE OF A STRONG POSITION
FOR A PAIR JUST LIKE I WOULD GET
EVER ANYONE DIETARY ADVICE, IT
WOULD BE A BAD IDEA.
HAVING SAID THAT, I DO FIND IT
INTERESTING NOW THAT, THEY ARE
CRITICIZING IN THE ESTATE OF
MIGRANTS AND HOW THEY ARE PUT IN
THIS HORRENDOUS SITUATION.
AND I DO NOT RECALL ANY OF THE
MAYORS IN THESE COMMUNITIES
SPREADING FOR THEIR CONDITION
AND HOW THEY WERE BEING TREATED
IN TEXAS, WHEN IT WAS JUST TEXAS
DEALING WITH IS, OR ARIZONA
DEALING WITH IS.
I DO NOT REMEMBER ONE OF THESE
GUYS TALKING ABOUT ME BETTER
THAN 900 FLIGHTS, AS I SAID,
OVER THE LAST TWO FISCAL YEAR IS
TO SO MANY LOCATIONS, BALTIMORE,
BUFFALO, CHICAGO, DALLAS,
BUFFALO, NEW YORK, COLUMBUS,
GEORGIA, I COULD GO ON AND ON
AND ON AND TO SAY ABOUT HOW MANY
OF THESE FLIGHTS LEFT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT, WITH NO
MORNING, HANDLED THROUGH ICE,
HANDLED THROUGH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND NO ONE SAID
BOO ABOUT THAT.
THAT IS WHAT KIND OF GALLS ME
BECAUSE IT IS VERY INCONSISTENT.
IT IS A DOUBLE STANDARD.
>> Chris: IT IS, NEIL, IT IS.
ESPECIALLY THOSE SAYING IT IS
UN-AMERICAN OR RECKLESS.
WHAT IS UN-AMERICAN AND RECKLESS
AS ENCOURAGING THESE MIGRANTS TO
MAKE THESE LONG DANGEROUS
JOURNEY WHEN MIGRANTS ARE DYING
CROSSING THE RIVER, DYING
CROSSING THE DESERT, BEING
SMUGGLED BY HUMAN SMUGGLERS.
THAT IS NOT A HUMANE PROCESS TO
HAVE IMMIGRATION.
WHAT THEY SHOULD DO, AND WHAT
THEY NEED TO HAVE A PLAN IS
HAVING A MORE CONTROLLED THE
FLOW OF IMMIGRANTS THAT ARE
COMING ACROSS OPPOSED TO HAVING
A PAY A CRIMINAL TO GET ACROSS A
RIVER AND SEEING A RECORD NUMBER
OF DEATHS FROM ADULTS TO
CHILDREN TRYING TO GET ACROSS
INTO THE UNITED STATES.
THAT IS NOT HUMANE.
WHAT WE ARE DOING IS A MORE
CONTROLLED STRATEGIES.
THESE IMMIGRANTS VOLUNTEERED TO
GET ON THESE BUSES, THEY ARE NOT
IN DANGER, THEY IT CAN GET OUT
ANYTIME THEY WANT DURING THIS
TRANSPORT.
SO, IT IS VERY, THE HYPOCRISY OF
THIS WHOLE SITUATION, NEIL, FROM
THESE NO GOALS SAYING WHAT WE
ARE DOING RIGHT NOW IS PLACING
THESE IMMIGRANTS IN DANGER.
WELL, THAT IS THE CONTROVERSY.
>> Neil: I'M SORRY YOUR FRIE